Uh,
today I'm going to try to talk a little bit more about Elizabeth Bishop and I'm
also going to,
uh,
try to give some big perspectives,
on the poet's we've been reading and,
and also,
uh,
some ways of thinking about how they fit together.
Um,
let's,
uh,
let's look at,
at Bishop's poem over 2000 illustrations and a complete concordance.
Uh,
the palm placed second in her second book called a cold spring published in
1955.
Uh,
the latest poems that we'll discuss in this course on,
on a Wednesday,
I talked about bishops,
poetics of geography or travel,
uh,
as,
as a horizontal poetics as opposed to the,
uh,
ascendant and sublime impulses,
in,
uh,
many of the poets that we have.
Um,
then examining this term,
uh,
this poetics is ultimately a poetry of Welsh shifting perspectives and local
perceptions.
Uh,
the question that it immediately poses is,
well,
how do we put these perceptions and he's points of view together.
Uh,
the,
I think,
uh,
exciting,
but also,
uh,
difficult,
textures of bishops,
Great Landscape Poems,
Florida,
Cape Breton,
uh,
at the fish houses.
A cold spring and others all pose this,
uh,
very clearly to us.
Uh,
this problem,
uh,
you might see the grains of sand that the sand Piper,
searches through,
uh,
in,
in that little poem Sandpiper as again,
exemplary of this problem.
And Bishop,
uh,
that is,
how do we hold on to organize,
uh,
find coherence in a world of a discreet and,
and shifting,
um,
uh,
phenomena.
This is the,
uh,
um,
really the,
the master problem,
uh,
that bishop addresses a very self consciously in this palm,
over 2000 illustrations in a complete concordance,
uh,
like the map.
It's a poem that,
that,
uh,
is in part about a representation.
Um,
she,
uh,
by implication begins the poem by referring to a book,
presumably the one mentioned in the title over 2000 illustrations and a complete
concordance.
What kind of book is that?
Uh,
she doesn't specify,
but as the palm unfolds,
there's reason to believe it's a bible.
I think perhaps a Family Bible.
Uh,
she says,
thus should have been our travels serious engraver bubble.
Uh,
our travels,
our experience in the world,
our experience of geography,
uh,
our experience as geography should have been,
ought to be serious.
It ought to add up to something and not to be in grievable,
something that that might be bound in book form.
Uh,
the image of a book with illustrations and a complete concordance,
uh,
holds up in idea,
um,
that,
word and image,
uh,
perhaps word and flesh,
representation and a experience might be bound together in a coherent unity.
Uh,
might be,
uh,
um,
shown to,
uh,
exist in,
in,
in concordance or in some kind of correspondence,
uh,
against this ideal or this model of things where illustration and text or are
bound together.
Uh,
bishop poses her own way,
word,
experience her travels,
which this poem will,
uh,
list,
record,
uh,
give us fragments of,
what the poem reveals to us is a world of discrete fragments,
uh,
parts that gain meaning if at all,
through their near adjacency,
uh,
or through the perceiver who holds them together,
holds them together through the quality of her attention,
uh,
and the sensibility behind it.
Uh,
a form of attention for bishop that is always pushing towards revelation,
uh,
seeking meaning something beyond surface detail but never quite arrives.
They're never in that sense,
arrives at a place of repose,
a or rest a or home.
Uh,
let me read the second paragraph,
which,
uh,
brilliantly represents,
the world,
uh,
brought into being by this,
poetics of geography entering the narrows at Saint John.
The touching bleed of goats reached our ship.
We glimpse them reddish,
leaping up the cliffs among the fog,
so weeds and butter and eggs.
And at Saint Peter's,
the wind blew in.
The Sun shone madly,
rapidly,
purposefully.
The Collegians mark marched in the lions criss crossing the great square with
black like ants.
The poem is composed almost of the fragments of a travel diary or bits of a
letter a.
And if you read bishops letter,
you will indeed find starvations,
uh,
like this,
on every page in Mexico,
the dead man lay and a blue arcade,
the dead volcanoes glistened like Easter Lilies,
the Juke box went on playing,
ah,
Olesko LEASCO and Volvulus there were beautiful poppy's splitting the mosaics.
The fat old guide made eyes
in Dingle Harbor and,
and we,
we jerk from one place to another,
uh,
with each sentence.
One Country,
a one spot on the map in dingle harbor,
a golden length of evening.
The rotting hulks held up there,
dripping plush.
The English women poured tea informing us that the duchess was going to have a
baby.
And this is one of bishops provocative juxtapositions in the poem.
And in the brothels of Marrakech,
the little pock marked prostitutes balanced their tea trays on their heads and
did their belly dances flung themselves naked and giggling against our knees
asking for cigarettes.
It was somewhere near there.
I saw what frightened me most of all,
implying of course that all of these scenes had frightened her.
A holy grave,
not looking particularly holy.
One of a group under a Keyhole,
Archstone bowel Deakin open to every wind from the pink desert,
an open gritty marble trough carved solid with exhortation.
Yellowed as scattered cattle teeth half filled with dust,
not even the dust of the poor profit.
Panem who once lay there just dust in a smart Bernice cut.
Dewar presumably their guide looked on amused.
Looking at these,
uh,
looking at this,
this series,
uh,
this,
this way bishops life seems to add up.
Uh,
she continues ref reflecting on the poem and on,
uh,
it's a structure.
Everything only connected by and,
and,
and
open the book.
And we're back to the book now.
That ideal form of,
uh,
representation in which text and image are bound.
The guilt rubs off the edges of the pages and pollinates the fingertips.
Bishop wants us as in the map to what she wants to.
The book has something that can be held and touched.
Uh,
she said,
a marvelously tactile poet,
along with the unity of experience that it promises to give us,
is a sense of intimacy to,
uh,
with an object open the heavy book.
She says to us,
why couldn't we have seen this old Nativity while we were at it?
The dark ajar,
the rocks breaking with light and undisturbed and breathing flame,
colorless,
sparkless freely fed on Straw and load within a family with pets
and looked and looked.
Our infant site away.
The Nativity is the scene of the incarnation.
Uh,
that moment when the word is made flesh Christmas morning.
that moment when the divine takes human form
and so,
uh,
becomes present in the world.
Uh,
this is specifically here as bishop imagines that a scene of revelation,
that wonderful phrase,
the dark jar as if the shadow,
we're a door and you could enter it,
uh,
the rocks breaking with light,
that which is solid opening.
What emerges is a flame,
a sign of spirit.
But notice how in this light,
the sacred is secularized.
My bishop finds there is not the holy family,
but a family with pets.
There is a nostalgia in here in this poem,
poignant and powerful that is in the style Jah,
uh,
not so much for the holy as for the family once constituted by their relation to
the holy
family with pets,
but also the family that gathered around the book to look at them.
Uh,
uh,
family gathered through religious practice,
who might then have looked and looked our infant site away,
uh,
in that,
looking is a,
uh,
expressed a kind of primal longing for community,
for human connection,
belonging expressed through looking importantly for bishop,
which is really what the poet is doing in the map.
I think,
uh,
in the way that she invites us into her act of looking in that poem.
Uh,
here,
Bishops Nostalgia is sad,
uh,
but also resigned.
Uh,
this negativity is a scene that can be remembered and looked at from afar,
but not entered into
as the belief system that it comes out of and,
and refers to.
It can be looked at from afar,
but not entered into
a bishop.
As several people remarked in section this week,
uh,
calls us back in lots of different ways to frost.
Frost is perhaps an unusual place to begin a course on modern poetry,
uh,
because remember him.
Uh,
he really is,
uh,
generally an exception,
to the metropolitan scene and inspiration of modern poetry.
Modern poetry is a poetry of the city,
of the metropolis of the world's city,
the place where the world's people's goods,
languages,
traditions,
and cultures are all accessible.
To use Marianne Moore's word from her poem,
New York,
uh,
pound,
Eliot crane,
more Hughes,
even Williams and Stevens in there.
It's somewhat different ways are all poets of the metropolis.
Uh,
the sense of ambivalence about modernity in these poets,
uh,
isn't ambivalence in many ways about the city and what it promises and also what
it in many ways,
uh,
threatens us with their sense of,
experience.
Their visions of modernity and of modern forms of community are all located in
expressed there.
Frost aggressively defines his work against that context.
Uh,
in doing this,
he links his writing to 19th century American writing and art,
uh,
links his writing to rural culture,
which dominates the 19th century.
There is a,
an anti modern strain in frost just as there is in Yates,
uh,
and,
more complex Lee impound.
And in Elliot,
what's modern about frost is what has changed in the rural cultures that he
writes about.
Uh,
that is the collapse of farming economies,
uh,
in communities in the decay of 19th century Protestantism,
the white church and the village green.
You feel that loss in the terrific aloneness of frosts people.
The Great Poem Directive,
uh,
is about all of these things.
Uh,
Frost's poetry
struggles to incorporate the secular truth of modern science and,
uh,
to make poetry,
to make poetry like science,
a disenchanted knowledge in this way.
A frost has a lot in common with Ogden.
Uh,
and frost,
again,
like garden is fundamentally concerned with poetry as a form of knowledge,
a way to know the world
at the same time.
Uh,
poetry preserves for frost,
certain,
uh,
archaic,
primitive powers of enchantment powers associated with primitive motives,
childhood experience that make it a crucial alternative to science and
scientific knowing.
Think of the magic trick at the end of directive when a frost takes us to the
ruined house of 19th century culture,
the ruin farmhouse of home burial maybe in steals from the abandoned children's
playhouse,
a broken drinking goblet like the grail and uses it to invite us to drink from a
primal source,
too lofty and original to rage that Spring
and in drinking to be whole again beyond confusion.
What are we drinking there?
Then at the end of frost poem,
this poem published the end of the Second World War were drinking kind of
elemental power,
uh,
that seems to fuse language and longing and imagination.
Uh,
this is in frost,
a conscious rewriting,
I think,
uh,
partially even a send up as well as a competition with Elliot in the wasteland.
Uh,
and the grail myths that are one of the central motifs of that poem,
one of the central motifs that embody for Elliot,
uh,
a sense of the holy,
which is present.
However,
for Elliot,
uh,
only through literary illusion,
something fascinating but unavailable,
uh,
as actual experience,
something available only in a sense as quotation poetry,
uh,
in frost as an Elliot does the work religion no longer does.
Uh,
but notice how in Frost
indirective,
uh,
the belief that poetry asks from us is a belief in a fiction in make believe.
Uh,
and in this,
uh,
frost is a strangely and wonderfully and surprisingly,
perhaps fully the contemporary of Wallace Stevens and Hart Crane whose work,
uh,
proceeds from that same assumption.
Stephens is a wartime poem.
Asides on the oboe,
uh,
begins the prologues are over.
It is a question now of final belief.
So say that final belief must be in a fiction.
It is time to choose.
This is the theme of Stevens is wartime masterpiece notes towards a supreme
fiction.
I noticed the contradictory impulses in Stevens,
his title,
uh,
when,
when poetry takes the place of religion for Stevens,
it presents itself as a supreme fiction,
uh,
a total representation of the world and experience.
But we only have partial provisional access to that fiction.
What Steven's gives us as merely notes,
notes
something that Elizabeth Bishop might present us with.
Two.
Uh,
in this sense in Stephens,
the shift from religion to poetry is also a shift from total ization,
uh,
from system to contingency and incompletion,
to parts,
uh,
rather than,
a whole
for Stevens.
Uh,
the disappearance of the Christian God as the center of,
uh,
emotional and spiritual cultural life,
is essentially,
however a cause for celebration
in Elliot.
It's a cause for mourning,
mourning and anxiety,
uh,
distress
in Yates.
It's a cause of fascination in horror
in crane for the making of new myths,
new metaphors
he uses secular poems are Christ haunted,
uh,
Christ in all of the,
iconography associated with him is a source of hope and also irony for black
culture and a reproach to the white world.
How do people,
how does culture find bearing,
uh,
in a world without divine sanction?
This has played out,
played out as an ethical question,
a question about how to live and act rightly,
uh,
in more.
And then later in Bishop,
uh,
in general,
it is a less urgent question,
uh,
less central one in the later poets than in the earlier ones.
Things fall apart.
The center cannot hold.
Yeats says in the second coming eat bishop is a fundamentally at home in this
condition,
which is a condition of center lessness or homelessness.
She liked the phrase,
uh,
the world's an orphans home in more,
bishop is,
uh,
at home then with a certain kind of homelessness,
travel as her metaphor for the new mobility of consciousness,
uh,
in a world without a stable center.
Her poetry is written from the disc disturbingly and disorienting Lee de
centered point of view that we find already in those early poems of her as a
point of view that takes for granted the absence of central authority that
religion wants provided.
Remember in over 2000 and illustrations and a complete concordance that holy
grave,
it's not even particularly holy.
She says,
uh,
the place of the sacred in bishop has been vacated.
Might poetry fill it.
This isn't a question bishop asks are as concerned with,
but it is,
is I've been suggesting an urgent one in many ways for the poets who proceeded
her,
uh,
the poetry of the period 1910 through 1940 say,
really the,
the,
uh,
great phase of modern poetry.
Uh,
this period is,
is structured.
I think my two big questions,
how should poetry be written and
what can it do?
What can it accomplish in the world?
In the first lecture,
uh,
I talked about these different impulses which are,
at once opposing but also I think related in interlocking,
uh,
I called one of them,
formal and inward turning an aesthetic,
uh,
the other rather outward turning,
concerned with the moral,
the political,
the social.
The first one tends to limit the definition of poetry to say what is particular
to this art to isolate what is essential to it.
The other works to extend poetry's scope,
uh,
to give it an expanded role in culture in the world,
in our lives.
You see different versions of both of these impulses in the career trajectories
of HD and William Carlos Williams,
uh,
who begin as a masters of a certain kind of,
short poem and go on to create a epic poems,
uh,
of,
cultural sweep,
a hds being called trilogy.
Williams is Patterson,
but the poet who more than any embodies these,
these two,
uh,
impulses,
in the shape of his career,
his pound of course,
uh,
as I said,
the author of the shortest and the longest poem,
uh,
in modern poetry,
the,
uh,
exponent of images and,
and,
uh,
the author of the cantos images and seems to want to get outside of history to
explore the sudden liberation from space limits and time limits.
Pan says in a kind of autonomous aesthetic experience,
the Cantos,
however,
our poem as pound called it,
including history upon,
uh,
of the greatest possible range and scope and ambitious
in images.
And there's an attempt to establish,
uh,
the primary poetic unit,
to cut away what is inessential,
uh,
to,
find,
uh,
what is true.
This is a kind of formal program that expresses a drive towards truth telling
and that we find in somewhat different terms in frost and Auden and more,
uh,
think of frost sense of fact versus in mowing the,
easy gold at the hand of fate or elf or a think of Yates is stylistic
transformation as expressed in that short poem,
a coat,
uh,
or the fishermen palms from 1915,
think about Moore's and Auden's severe revisions,
uh,
of their work,
in each case involving cutting out poems or cutting away,
uh,
many lines,
in order to arrive at what more called in poetry,
that poem,
subjected to severe revision,
the genuine,
uh,
these are all creative acts of,
I think you could say self limitation.
Uh,
and,
uh,
they are linked to the general recurrent theme in these poets.
Um,
uh,
in these poets in particular on more frost,
to the general theme of restraint or reticence.
The deepest feeling always shows itself in silence,
not in silence,
but restraint.
Uh,
remember Auden's stone,
God that never was more reticent,
always afraid to say more than he meant.
This impulse that I'm describing in modern poetry is also related to formal
experiments.
Uh,
uh,
with this restraint,
you,
you see this worked into a Morris syllabics,
uh,
modern poetry in many ways,
seeks to restrain the singing voice in the lyric voice of romantic poetry as
received through 19th century poetry frosts vernacular,
uh,
his,
his will to get the sound of sense into,
uh,
his poems,
functions in this way.
So does Hughes's vernacular his black speech,
uh,
think about,
Elliot's syntactic and logical discontinuity and disjunctions,
uh,
the way they,
interrupt,
uh,
and and fragment a lyric utterance or think about pounds,
incorporation of blocks of pros as he did in the cantos.
Uh,
there is in all of these examples of tendency to define what is modern and
modern poetry by the incorporation of traditionally non poetic forms of speech
and language use.
And Moreover,
and importantly,
non traditional methods of organizing poetic language.
At the same time,
this impulse can be seen as a way not of of uh,
uh,
limiting or curtailing poetry's scope,
but rather the opposite,
expanding it,
expanding it to include,
uh,
even as more puts it schoolbooks and business documents making poetry available
for people and cultures and experience that had not previously been represented
in poetry.
Other modern poetry is experimental in a very different way.
I indeed in its,
uh,
a revival in recovery and incorporation of a historical poetic forms you could
understand a heart cranes were claiming of Elizabethan and um,
uh,
19th century,
forms of,
of uh,
or in a mental rhetoric,
uh,
and uh,
versification as exactly this kind of,
um,
a reclaiming of,
uh,
archaic materials.
There's something similar going on in,
uh,
in pounds,
in pounds recovery of province,
Sol and Anglo Saxon.
A verse forms is his revival of these,
uh,
forms pound and crane are both heroic poets.
Uh,
they answer that question,
what can poetry do?
What can it affect and culture by saying simply everything.
Uh,
that's really the extraordinary,
uh,
presumption of their long poems.
The bridge and the Qantas,
they are very different poets.
Uh,
however,
in to some extent exposed,
exposed oposed figures,
although indeed,
uh,
their,
their claims for poetry make made them both,
uh,
exposed,
figures,
um,
in,
uh,
poignant and complicated ways.
When I talk about the difference,
I'm thinking of pounds,
suspicion of rhetoric,
uh,
his suspicion of representation is kind of will or drive to get beyond these
things,
uh,
versus cranes,
faith in rhetoric,
uh,
faith and rhetoric and imagination,
in their power to transform the world.
In a sense,
you couldn't have two more different poets,
but both of these poets take poetry as a kind of metaphor,
uh,
as not only a metaphor,
but as the,
as the salient instance of the creative impulse in history.
What makes history happen?
What makes,
uh,
action,
in history,
uh,
and they place poetry,
at the center of all that is most important that we do.
They both propose that poetry can fulfill the central mediating functions that
religion once did,
pound and crane become cautionary figures for later poets.
Uh,
to some extent,
Yates does too.
Uh,
that is,
uh,
figures who seem to show the limits of poetry precisely in their efforts to
expand them.
Uh,
this is one way we can understand a bishop's palm visits to Saint Elizabeth's on
page one 33,
uh,
this is a poem that describes
okay
bishops periodic visits to Ezra pound in Saint Elizabeth's hospital where pounds
was,
uh,
institutionalized incarcerated,
after his return to the United States on charges of treason.
Uh,
bishop was living in Washington as the poetry consultant to the Librarian of
Congress,
and it befell her almost as an official duty to,
uh,
visit pound a,
hear him talk and bring people to pounds.
Uh,
and it became the occasion for this poem,
uh,
built on the form of,
this is the House that Jack built.
This is the,
this is the poetry that Jack made.
This is the house of Betalin.
This is the man that lives in the house of Bedlam.
And this is the time of the tragic man that lives in the house of Bedlam.
And she continues adding each time,
adding and of course,
in bishops,
uh,
distinctive manner,
not only repeating,
but revising the terms that she's given us.
Uh,
again,
uh,
you know,
a poetics of constant readjustment,
uh,
as the,
poem builds,
uh,
characters are included.
Not only a pound,
but a pound represented as the man,
but also soldier,
a boy,
a Jew,
uh,
figures that are
okay
versions of pound,
perhaps,
uh,
reaching a climax,
in the final stanza.
This is the soldier home from the war.
Perhaps that's pound in some sense.
Uh,
these are the years in the walls and the door that shut on a boy,
the pats the floor to see if the world is round or flat.
Again,
bishop touching a map.
This is a Jew in a newspaper hat.
The dance is carefully down the wall ward walking the plank of a coffin board
with the crazy sailor that shows us.
Watch the,
tells the time of the wretched man who lives in the house of Bedlam.
It's a great poem.
Uh,
I spoke of audits and bishops.
Perspectivism.
Uh,
here,
bishop gives us multiple perspectives on pound and by extension on the social
and political ambitions of modernist poetry.
Pound is tragic,
talkative,
honored,
old,
brave,
cranky,
cruel.
And finally,
simply wretched.
A word that comes from the seafarer.
Arguably,
uh,
one strain of modern poetry ends here in 1950 in the madhouse.
In Bedlam.
Importantly,
though it is not that bishop stands apart from in a position to judge
pound
instead,
she is interestingly,
I think,
implicated in the scene.
Uh,
she must've enjoyed and by her choice of title calls attention to the irony that
pound is,
uh,
in a mad house that has the same name as Bishop,
in Bishop's Great War palm roosters.
Uh,
there is a sense that,
uh,
to,
oppose a conflict,
uh,
out in the world when must encounter conflict in oneself.
Uh,
here too.
I think in multiple ways,
bishop implicates herself in the objects of her critique and satire.
Uh,
the child's verse form,
it's important,
uh,
bishop identifies with,
I think it's fair to say she's certainly interested in children throughout her
poetry.
Uh,
this interest points,
I think to bishop sense of herself as a minor poet that is,
um,
a map maker,
uh,
not a historian,
a poet who refuses to write the major culturally central aggressively,
uh,
ambitious poetry too,
which modernism and above all the poetry of pound aspired,
uh,
Arden's perspectivism in music.
They are,
seems to position the poet and poetry similarly.
So it has that famous statement,
uh,
in the Yates Allergy for poetry makes nothing happen.
Uh,
these poems mutate a bazaar in memory of WB Yeats read like rebukes to modern is
promethian ambitions.
It's a verticality.
Uh,
if you like,
uh,
rebukes to,
to Auden's own political poetry of the 1930s,
exemplified by a poem like Spain,
1937.
Uh,
but uh,
as I stressed odd and doesn't put a full stop on that sentence for poetry makes
nothing happen.
Rather he punctuates it with a colon in,
continues it survives
a,
there is perhaps a double implication here either poetry does not have an effect
in the world,
but still survives despite its lack of making something happen or it survives
because it makes nothing happen.
It is not a cause,
uh,
and it doesn't take up causes effectively what it does rather as odd and
represents it.
Here is creative space,
a space of happening,
uh,
landscape,
a model of the world scene in the same time,
uh,
as a valley and a river,
the river that flows through it.
There's terrific power of affirmation,
uh,
in this claim about poetry survival at the moment of the eight staff at the
moment,
uh,
of the,
onset of the Second World War when all the dogs of Europe Bark,
uh,
ultimately in Ogden,
poetry survives as a way of happening as he calls it.
That is a way in the sense of both a method and a path,
uh,
and,
implicitly,
uh,
as I suggested talking about this poem earlier,
it's survives as a kind of open space,
a place to come into,
uh,
to,
collect in and gather in,
uh,
for us.
Uh,
and it is figured,
I think,
uh,
finally,
implicitly as a mouth,
uh,
the human mouth open to speak,
old words and,
and new words to a poetry survives in,
in my mouth,
uh,
and also in yours.
Uh,
which seems like a good last sentence too,
in this course with,
so thank you very much.
[inaudible].